he ate a 3-2 win 10 seconds 1 raid
against equal dolla 5 seconds well
waiters back to twig shoots no I
couldn't get it off that fires it
[Applause]
26 to go to 20
points second quarter in this game
Winslow and the wave three on the way
124 123 and the heat foul Durant let's
take a closer look here on your Street
totally off Baptist puffs the glass
circus shot and Wade the hero once again
in his final game against the Golden
State Warriors Dwyane Wade beats two
worries an improbable unlikely finish
falling backwards I mean everything
possible to make it hard that was a 12
on a scale of one to ten that he's still
able that second one though it got
hectic Wayne what was going through your
mind is that ball is kind of bubbling
around a little bit well first of all
Kevin Durant
is an animal man I mean hit every beat
shot same as he did in Game one when we
played him up there but you know we just
kept fighting and now kept believing and
the ball bobbled around and everything
and I just gotta just try to get it up
in the good Lord put it in for me so I'm
very thankful right now
I'm a little overwhelmed right now man
there's been a while since the moment
like that I guess it seemed like that